d'accord c'est
marrant il y a une fissure sur la glace
ouais il passe dessus maintenant ouais tu le vois
ouais on vient juste de passer dessus d'accord
ils m'ont donné d'arrêter d'enregistrer maintenant ouais
petite euh dérive de neige sur la fissure
c'est comme une petite montagne ouais
d'accord arrête d'enregistrer
avant  ce titre d'
accord
un peu d'éclat là-bas je viens un
peu aussi il y a
des oiseaux là-bas qui
se battent avec ça
oh
devant le jour
oh les animaux
oui mais les oiseaux pouvez-vous juste lui donner
plus d'exposition je ne peux pas tout à fait  le voir
d'accord là nous allons
n'importe quel animal ou quoi que ce soit non je
cherche je ne trouve rien
au-dessus de l'eau sous
l'avis de circulation 22 décimal un et ils
ont chassé pour agir zone Premières années
cinq huit zéro huit ici ne sont tout simplement pas
botter leur  directeur quatre mille pieds
en montée deux niveaux de vol
s
5808 1267 d'accord
eh bien je ne peux pas dire grand-chose euh je ne
vois rien dans l'eau ouais
avis de circulation 26-7 dans le
coup de pied leur zone de piste c'est le premier il y a
cinq huit zéro huit huit niveau  42
arrêtez juste de donner un coup de pied à Star Trek dans la montée cette
fois à 4700 pieds niveau deux deux zéro Cal
avec sa prochaine recrue Vice verset 126 vers le haut
les deux oiseaux volent vers notre droite
c'est comment ça va
jusqu'à la fin de celui-ci  juste pour voir ce qu'il y a
ici ouais je pense que nous avons fait tout le chemin
ici
euh d'accord
mieux probablement je ne peux rien voir
de plus là-bas c'est un peu de
vent à la fin ouais c'est à peu près il
n'y a pas d'ondulations sur l'eau alors allons  faites
demi-tour et allez à cet autre
endroit dans le nord attendez
hein d'accord
arrêtez d'enregistrer
c'est une lumière différente sur la glace
qu'avant ouais
c'est plutôt sympa en fait c'est les
faits saillants ça rend les faits saillants un
peu roses ouais d'accord
arrête d'enregistrer
ouais
bébé de  vers l'arrière ouais j'essaierai d'
essayer vers l'arrière dans un instant vers le bas
enlevez ce petit point d'évasement là allons-y
pouvons-nous aller juste un peu
plus haut mettre de la hauteur ouais
tourne juste ici
je suis toujours
ouais
d'accord
dézoomer je suis zoomé  ouais
totalement ouais
je pourrais probablement m'incliner
lentement en m'inclinant lentement jusqu'au
prochain carré tourne à gauche là-haut
oh non se lever
c'est une bonne chose
d'accord nous nous dirigeons vers les nuages
ici ok ok ok ok
d'accord d'accord d'accord
arrêtez d'enregistrer maintenant
ils sont comme verticaux ouais eh bien le ouais
pour changer légèrement le cap vers la
liste
20 degrés 15 degrés vers la gauche d'accord
maintenant vous pouvez maintenant vous redresser sur
l'original en frappant à nouveau
et si vous effectuez un zoom arrière qui est compressé  dehors
oh d'accord
en dessous d'
accord tournez simplement le cap vers la gauche d'un
peu environ 15 degrés
c'est bien
sur la droite
oh d'accord d'accord c'est bon
redescendons bonjour salut
Leela
tu es la bienvenue
quoi d'accord
arrête d'enregistrer
le soleil de minuit
ce que je viens de  mort maintenant je ne parle pas
de la boutique
qui a le soleil dans le plan
un peu de la vitrine mais
donc
je ne la vois pas d'accord
c'est marrant parce que c'est le genre de euh d'accord
arrête d'enregistrer ouais
arrête d'enregistrer